لن يحكم الكر والفر مسار الحرب في
اوكرانيا على ابواب مداخل الشتاء بل الثلج
هو من سيتحكم في مفاصل تلك الحرب في
الشتاء تنخفض درجات الحراره تتلاشى الطرق
والحقول هو تتحول الى ارض موحله تربح
الرجال والمعدات الطقس سيئ سيؤثر على
روسيا واوكرانيا في ان واحد من المرجح ان
يبطئ من وتيره القتال وان يتراجع مستوى
المعارك بنسبه الثلث في مثل هذه الحالات
يصبح تشغيل المعدات اكثر صعوبه ويمكن
اخفاء الالغام تحت الجليد
وستزداد الحاجه الى مزيد من الوقود
للمولدات وحتى الرصاص يقول ابطاء لان
الهواء البارد اكثر كثافه من الهواء
الدافئ كل ذلك يجبر التحركات العسكريه على
ان تتغير حيث ستلجا روسيا للضربات الجويه
كبديل التحرك بري اوكرانيا وبفضل
الامدادات الغربيه عقبه مناشدتها الداعمين
الغربيين بامتدادها بالاطقم والمعدات
ستكون على الارجح افضل تجهيزا من الروس
مقابل الدفع الكبير لجنودها للقتال
جنرال الثلج هو ما تنتظره روسيا لمساعدتها
كما فعل خلال القرون الماضيه لصدي تقدم
قوات نابليون وهتلر نحو موسكو تجربه اخرى
مقابله حرب الاتحاد السوفيتي ضد فلندا
والتي كانت مجهزه بشكل افضل للبرد وعلى
درايه بالتضاريس ما قلل خسائرها على الرغم
من استسلامها في النهايه
وهو الشتاء التجمد والثلج يذيب قواعد
الحرب ويغير مجراها تتصلب الارض ويصبح
القتال اكثر صعوبه عصام عبد السلام